valérie t aurais étè de tous les
événements et de toutes les bonnes
causes à whitehorse toujours avec le
sourire
enseignante dans une école d'immersion
artisanes et grande amateurs de plein
air la jeune femme de 37 ans et la
petite adèle dix mois avait de très
nombreux amis une amie exceptionnelle du
madeleine pius alès énormément de
positiver de de respect des jeunes
d'amour déjà de générosité d'un monde la
nature c'est la nature sauvage du conte
qu'il avait conquise avec son conjoint
et lire monroe should il s'était procuré
il ya trois ans un territoire de
piégeage à la frontière des territoires
du nord-ouest
parti en octobre pour un séjour de trois
mois le couple allait vivre un rêve en
famille un rêve qui a tourné au drame le
dit quand le trappeur est revenu à la
cabane en fait d'après midi et s'est
fait attaquer par une ourse grizzlies
qu'il a réussi à abattre sur le champ
valérie théorie la petite était déjà
morte tout près de là y'a aucune défense
contre 1 gressly on utilise des moyens
les bombes aérosol ça me fait à en vous
et moi ça fait sauvé qu'on peut et tu
m'as amd arm a fondé
mais si grizzlies attaque l' arme à feu
l'est où est ce que les charger ont dit
point grizzlies donne-moi de minutes
c'est une équipe de la grc d'agents de
conservation de la faune qui a ramené à
whitehorse le tracteur et guide de
chasse hier monroe scholtes et ce sont
les amis qui l'ont accueilli ça nous a
tous fait un grand bien de pouvoir enfin
voir que hier moan était avec nous puis
que de pouvoir lui dire à quel point on
en était là pour lui puis à quel point
on est riche on a pleuré beaucoup avec
murner on a eu aussi des beaux mots m'a
parlé de vale mais la communauté
francophone au vu qu'on compte quelques
1500 personnes
le vide laissé par la mort de valérie
théorêt se fera sentir pendant longtemps
c'est un choc
c'est un choc qui se répercute un peu
sur tout le monde c'est comme un effet
domino de la communauté francophone
c'est un village à whitehorse et au look
ans et donc quand quelqu'un de notre
communauté disparaît c'est toujours ça
toujours un effet sur tout le monde
l'association franco yukonnaise offrira
un service de soutien psychologique à
tous ceux qui pourraient en avoir besoin
entre temps les spécialistes de la faune
tentent de déterminer ce qui a pu
motiver la tacc de l'ours grizzli en ce
début d'hiver très doux et c'est claude
1 200 sans radio canada où un touriste